good good morning everybody and welcome
to the American Enterprise Institute i'm
danielle plate guy i'm the senior vice
president for foreign and defense policy
studies here at AEI we're a little tight
for time today so I'm not going to take
a lot of time with introductions I think
ambassador nikki Haley is well known to
most of you here she is the former
governor of South Carolina she is the
daughter of immigrants what a great
success story she is and she is now our
United Nations permanent representative
she increasingly has become too many
rogue nations around the world the voice
of America and a strong and clear one at
that let me just tell you quickly what
we're doing here today
ambassador Haley's going to come up to
the podium and deliver a short speech
and then we're gonna sit down do a
little conversation and take questions
from the audience and then we're gonna
clear the room and go
so with that ambassador Haley thank you
very much it's great to see so many
people in the room and thank you for
hosting me today Arthur Brooks is one of
the coolest people I know
conservative heart was brilliantly
written and impacted me greatly so I
value his friendship and the
contributions AI continues to make I'm
here today to speak about Iran and the
2015 nuclear agreement this is a topic
that should concern all Americans as it
has a serious impact on our national
security and the security of the world
it's a topic that comes up frequently at
the United Nations and it's a topic
we've been looking at carefully
including recently visiting with the
Iran nuclear monitors at the
International Atomic Energy Agency in
Vienna we were impressed by the IAEA
team and its efforts director general
Amano is a very capable that diplomat
and he's a serious person who clearly
understands the critical nature of his
task
in our discussion Amano made an
observation that stood out to me he said
that monitoring Iranian compliance with
the nuclear deal is like a jigsaw puzzle
picking up just one piece doesn't give
you the full picture that's a very
appropriate metaphor and it goes well
beyond the work of the IAEA it goes to
the entire way we must look at Iranian
behavior and American security interests
many observers missed that point they
think well as long as Iran is meeting
the limits on enriched uranium and
centrifuges then it's complying with the
deal that's not true this is a jigsaw
puzzle next month
president Trump will once again be
called upon to declare whether he finds
Iran in compliance with the terms of the
deal it should be noted that this
requirement to assess compliant does not
come from the deal itself it was created
by Congress in the Iran nuclear
agreement review Act also known as the
corker Cardin law that's a very
important distinction to keep in mind
because many people confuse the
requirements of the deal with the
requirements of US law I'm not going to
prejudge in any way what the president
is going to decide next month while I
have discussed it with him I do not know
what decision he will make it is his
decision to make and his alone it's a
complicated question the truth is the
Iran deal has so many flaws that it's
tempting to leave it but the deal was
constructed in a way that makes leaving
it less attractive
it gave Iran what it wanted up front in
exchange for temporary promises to
deliver what we want that's not good
Iran was feeling the pinch of
international sanctions in a big way in
the two years before the deal was signed
Iran's GDP actually shrunk by more than
four
percent in the two years since the deal
and the lifting of sanctions Iran's GDP
has grown by nearly five percent that's
a great deal for them what we get from
the deal is not so clear I'm here to
outline some of the critical
considerations that must go into any
analysis of Iranian compliance and I
hope to debunk some of the
misperceptions about the decision the
president will face next month the
question of Iranian compliance is not as
straightforward as many people believe
it's not just about the technical terms
of the nuclear agreement it requires a
much more thorough look Iranian
compliance involves three different
pillars the first is the nuclear
agreement itself the joint comprehensive
plan of action or jcpoa the second
pillar is UN Security Council resolution
to 231 which endorsed the nuclear deal
but also restricted numerous other
Iranian behaviors and the third pillar
is the corker Cardin law which governs
the president's relationship with
Congress as it relates to Iran policy
before diving into these details it's
important to lay a foundation for
exactly what we're dealing with when we
talk about the Iranian regime judging
any international agreement begins and
ends with the nature of the government
that signed it does it respect
international law can it be trusted to
abide by its commitments is the
agreement strong enough to withstand the
regime's attempt to cheat given those
answers is the agreement in the natural
in the national interests of the United
States the Islamic Republic of Iran was
born in an act of international law
breaking on November 4th 1979 a group of
islamic revolutionary students over ran
the US Embassy in Tehran
in violation of international law they
held 52 American marines and diplomats
hostage for 444 days for the 38 years
since the Iranian regime has existed
outside the community of law-abiding
Nations Henry Kissinger famously said
that Iran can't decide whether it is a
nation or a cause since 1979 the regime
has behaved like a cause the cause of
spreading revolutionaries Shiite Islam
by force its main enemy and rallying
point has been and continues to be what
it calls the Great Satan the United
States of America and the regime's main
weapon in pursuit of its revolutionary
aims has been the Islamic Revolutionary
Guard Corps or IRGC soon after the
Revolution the IRGC was correct was
created to protect the revolution from
its foreign and domestic enemies the
IRGC reported not to elected government
but to the supreme leader alone soon
after its own creation the IRGC founded
Hezbollah to spread Iran's influence and
its revolution abroad then came the
bombing of the US Embassy in Beirut in
1983 63 Americans killed then came the
bombing of the Marine Barracks 241
Americans killed then the kidnapping and
murder of CIA station chief William
Buckley in 1985 a TWA airplane was
hijacked the body of a u.s. Navy diver
was dumped on the runway at the Beirut
Airport in 1988 u.s. Marine Colonel
Robert Higgins a UN peacekeeper in south
Lebanon was kidnapped and executed under
the IRGC direction Hezbollah then
expanded its lethal reach to Europe
Africa Asia and the Americas
in search of victims to kill in 1994 a
Jewish Community Center in Buenos Aires
was bombed 85 killed in 1996 a truck
bomb blew up khabar towers in Saudi
Arabia 19 us Airmen killed throughout
the Iraq war the number one killer of US
troops was improvised explosive devices
or IEDs the deadliest of which were
supplied by the IRGC thousands of
American men and women were wounded or
killed in 2005 Lebanese Prime Minister
Rafik Hariri was assassinated in 2011
the u.s. disrupted an IRGC plot to bomb
an American restaurant less than two
miles from here the target was the Saudi
ambassador today Hezbollah is doing the
Iranian regime's dirty work supporting
the war crimes of Syria's Assad and it
is building an arsenal of weapons and
battle-hardened fighters in Lebanon in
preparation for war this is the nature
of the regime and its quest to overturn
the international order its power and
influence has grown over time even as it
remains unaccountable to the Iranian
people it's hard to find a conflict or
suffering people in the Middle East that
the Iranian regime the IRGC or the
proxies do not touch in parallel with
its support for terrorism and proxy wars
Iran's military has long pursued nuclear
weapons all while attempting to hide its
intentions for decades the Iranian
military conducted a covert nuclear
weapons program undeclared and hidden
from international inspectors in 2002
Iranian dissidents revealed the
existence of a uranium enriched
enrichment plant and heavy water reactor
both violations of Iran's safeguards
agreement with the IAEA
the regime went on to break multiple
promises to abide by international
inspections and limits it hid its
nuclear weapons development and lied
about it until it got caught in 2009
American British and French intelligence
revealed the existence of a secret
uranium enrichment plant deep inside a
mountain deep inside an IR GC base the
British prime minister sub summed up
Iran's behavior well calling it quote
the serial deception of many years it
was soon after this that President Obama
began negotiating a deal with Iran the
deal he struck wasn't supposed to be
just about nuclear weapons it was meant
to be an opening with Iran a welcoming
back into the community of nations
President Obama believed that after
decades of hostility to the u.s. the
Iranian regime was willing to negotiate
an end to its nuclear program much has
been written about the jcpoa I won't
repeat it all here let's just say what
the that the agreement falls short of
what was promised we were promised an
end to the Iranian nuclear program what
emerged was not an end but a pause under
the deal Iran will continue to enrich
uranium and develop advanced centrifuges
we were promised Anytime Anywhere
inspections of sites in Iran the final
agreement delivered much less the
promised 24/7 inspections apply only to
Iran's declared nuclear sites for any
undeclared but suspected sites the
regime can deny access for up to 24 days
then there's the deals expiration dates
after 10 years the limits on uranium
advanced centrifuges and other nuclear
restrictions begin to evaporate and in
less than 10 years they had the
opportunity to upgrade their
capabilities
in various ways the jcpoa is therefore a
very flawed and limited agreement but
even so Iran has been caught in multiple
violations over the past year and a half
in February 2016 just a month after the
agreement was implemented the IAEA
discovered Iran had exceeded its
allowable limit of heavy water nine
months later Iran exceeded the heavy
water limit again both times the Obama
administration helped Iran get back into
compliance and refused to declare it a
violation if that's not enough the
biggest concern is that Iranian leaders
the same ones who in the past were
caught operating a covert nuclear
program at military sites have stated
publicly that they will refuse to allow
IAEA inspections of their military sites
how can we know Iran is complying with
the deal if inspectors are not allowed
to look everywhere they should look
another major flaw in the jcpoa is its
penalty provisions whether an Iranian
violation is big or small whether it is
deed material or non material the deal
provides for only one penalty that
penalty is the real position of
sanctions and if sanctions re-imposed
Iran is then freed from all of its
commitments that it made think about
that there is an absurdly circular logic
to enforcement of this deal penalizing
its violations don't make the deal
stronger they blow it up Iran's leaders
know this they are counting on the world
brushing off relatively minor
infractions or even relatively major
ones they are counting on the United
States and the other parties to the
agreement being so invested in its
success that they overlook Iranian
cheating that is exactly what our
previous administration did
it is this unwillingness to challenge
Iranian behavior for fear of damaging
the nuclear agreement that gets to the
heart of the threat the deal imposes to
our national security the Iranian
nuclear deal was designed to be too big
to fail the deal drew an artificial line
between the Iranian regime's nuclear
development and the rest of its lawless
behavior it said we've made this deal on
the nuclear side so none of the regime's
other bad behavior is important enough
to threaten the nuclear agreement the
result is that for advocates of the deal
everything in our relationship with the
Iranian regime must now be subordinated
to the preservation of the agreement the
Iranians understand this dynamic just
last month when the United States
imposed new sanctions in response to
Iranian missile launches Iran's leaders
threatened once again to leave the jcpoa
and return to a nuclear program more
advanced than the one they had before
the agreement this arrogant threat tells
us one thing Iran's leaders want to use
the nuclear deal to hold the world
hostage to its bad behavior this threat
is a perfect example of how judging the
regime's nuclear plans strictly in terms
of compliance with the jcpoa is
dangerous and short-sighted more
importantly it misses the point why did
we need to prevent the Iranian regime
from acquiring nuclear weapons in the
first place the answer has everything to
do with the nature of the regime and the
IRGC s determination to threaten Iran's
neighbors and advance its revolution and
that is where the other two pillars that
connect us to the nuclear deal come into
play the second pillar directly involves
the United Nations when the nuclear
agreement was signed the Obama
administration took Iran's non-nuclear
activity the missile development the arm
smuggling the terrorism this
sort of murderous regimes and rolled it
up into UN Security Council resolution
two to three one critically included in
this supposed non-nuclear activity is
the IRG cease ongoing development of
ballistic missile technology you can
call it non-nuclear all you want missile
technology cannot be separated from the
pursuit of a nuclear weapon
North Korea is showing the world that
right now every six months the UN
secretary-general reports to the
Security Council on the Iranian regime's
compliance with this so-called
non-nuclear resolution each report is
filled with devastating evidence of
Iranians violations proven arms
smuggling violations of travel bans
ongoing support for terrorism stoking of
regional conflicts the Secretary
General's report also includes ample
evidence of ballistic missile technology
and launches the regime has engaged in
such launches repeatedly including in
July of this year when it launched a
rocket into space that intelligence
experts say can be used to develop an
intercontinental ballistic missile they
are clearly acting in defiance of UN
resolution to 231 by developing missile
technology capable of deploying nuclear
warheads unfortunately as happens all
too often at the UN many member states
choose to ignore blatant violations of
the UN's
own resolutions in this way we see how
dangerously these two pillars of Iran
policy work together the international
community has powerful incentives to go
out of its way to assert that the
Iranian regime is in compliance on the
nuclear side meanwhile the UN is too
reluctant to address the regime's
so-called non-nuclear violations the
result is that Iran's military continues
its march towards the missile technology
to deliver a nuclear warhead and the
world becomes a more dangerous place
that's where the third pillar of our
Iran nuclear policy comes in the corker
Cardin law as you recall President Obama
refused to submit the Iran deal to
Congress as a treaty he knew full well
that commerce would have rejected it in
fact majorities in both houses of
Congress voted against the deal among
the no votes were leading Democrats like
senators Chuck Schumer Ben Cardin and
Bob Menendez despite President Obama's
constitutionally questionable dodge of
Congress the legislative body did
attempt to exercise some of its
authority with the passage of the corker
Cardin law the law requires that the
president make a certification to
Congress every 90 days but importantly
the law asks the president to certify
several things not just one the first is
that Iran has not materially breached
the jcpoa that's the one everyone
focuses on but the corker Cardin law
also requires something else something
that is often overlooked it asks the
president to certified the suspension of
sanctions against Iran certified that
the suspension of sanctions against Iran
is appropriate and proportionate to
Iran's nuclear measures and that it is
vital to the national security interests
of the United States so regardless of
whether one considers Iran's violations
of the jcpoa to have been material and
regardless of whether one considers
Iran's flouting of the UN resolution on
its ballistic missile technology to be
non-nuclear US law requires the
president to also look at whether the
Iran deal is appropriate proportionate
and in our national security interests
corker Cardin asked us to put together
the pieces of the jigsaw puzzle
under its structure we must consider not
just the Iranian regime's technical
violations of the jcpoa but also its
violations of resolution to 231 and its
long history of aggression we must
consider the regime's repeated
demonstrated hostility towards the
United States we must consider its
history of deception about its nuclear
program we must consider its ongoing
development of ballistic missile
technology and we must consider the day
when the terms of the jcpoa sunset
that's a day when Iran's military may
very well already have the missile
technology to send a nuclear warhead to
the United States a technology that
North Korea only recently developed in
short we must consider the whole picture
not simply whether Iran has exceeded the
jcpoa s limit on uranium enrichment we
must consider the whole jigsaw puzzle
not just one of its pieces that's the
judgment president Trump will have to
make in October and if the president
does not certify Iranian compliance the
corker Cardin law also tells us what
happens next what happens next is
significantly in Congress's hands this
is critically important and almost
completely overlooked if the president
chooses not to certify Iranian
compliance that does not mean the United
States is withdrawing from the jcpoa
withdrawal from the agreement is
governed by the terms of the jcpoa the
corker Cardin law governs the
relationship between the President and
Congress if the president finds that he
cannot certify Iranian compliance it
would signal one or more of the
following messages to Congress either
the administration believes Iran is in
violation of the deal or the lifting of
sanctions against Iran is not
appropriate and proportional to the
regime's behavior or the lifting of
sanctions
is not in the US national security
interest under the law Congress then has
60 days to consider whether to reimpose
sanctions on Iran during that time
Congress could take the opportunity to
debate Iran's support for terrorism its
past nuclear activity and its massive
human rights violations all of which are
called for in the corker Cardin Congress
could debate whether the nuclear deal is
in fact too big to fail we should
welcome a debate over whether the jcpoa
is in the US national security interest
the previous administration set up the
deal in a way that denied us that honest
and serious debate if the president
finds that he cannot in good faith
certify Iranian compliance he would
initiate a process whereby we move
beyond narrow technicalities and look at
the big picture at issue is our national
security interests it's past time we
have an Iran nuclear policy that
acknowledged that thank you thank you so
much thank you you've given us an
enormous amount to talk about and I'm
gonna use the mic as I always do to ask
first couple of questions so you were
just at a Security Council session that
was called urgently in the wake of a
potential hydrogen bomb test in North
Korea now you're talking about Iran a
different challenge but in many ways the
same kind of a challenge I mean how do
you do you see the possibility that Iran
ends up in a North Korea situation if
more is not done in the coming months
and years I think that's why it's so
important for me to talk about this
because I know that if we continue to
not look at the Iranian activity if we
continue to just say oh we'll deal with
that later we will be dealing
with the next North Korea because we're
allowing them to go and develop advanced
technology right there in front of us
we're allowing them to have behavior
that's in violation of the resolution
right in front of us we're allowing them
to sit there and actually tell the IAEA
they are not going to let them inspect
military sites where we know they have
had covert nuclear operations in the
past so what I want the country to
understand is we need to wake up we need
to understand this is not something that
just suddenly went away
it is still there but it's hiding behind
an agreement that has everyone so scared
to touch it without realizing things are
going on right now so you spend a lot of
time with our allies and and others I've
been up in New York one of the things
that you hear from from Iran and their
and their their friends and supporters
is if the United States chooses to walk
away from the jcpoa for whatever reason
the Europeans and the Asians and the
Russians are not going to be with them
you're going to be walking away on your
own and we're not going to put sanctions
back in place as you as you lay out your
concerns as you talk to people up in New
York where do you see our allies
standing on this I think our allies are
frustrated and they are concerned they
see what we see they see the violations
of the UN resolution they see the fact
that the Iranian regime is saying
they're not going to let us look at
military sites they're concerned
everyone hoped that this deal was going
to make the Iranian government good
people but no one looked at the history
of Iran no one looked at all the past
aggressions that they have shown and
what we're saying is this deal doesn't
change all that and this deal doesn't
change what's happening right now so our
allies very much know that we should be
concerned no they don't want us to get
out of the deal but this is the thing
are we gonna take care of our allies and
making sure they're comfortable or are
we going to look out for US security
interests
that's the thing this is about u.s.
national security this is not about
European security this is not about
anyone else this is about the president
making a decision on are we is this in
our national security interest to
continue down this path that we're on so
one of the things that got the Iranians
to the table were the sanctions that
that you mentioned that really took a
bite out of out of the Iranian economy
the challenge for us then is if the
assessment is that in fact they are not
complying that this is no longer in the
US national interest how do we how do we
constrain them this is one of the
conversations that a lot of people have
in Washington we focus a lot on the
jcpoa okay it's a lousy deal but it was
a carefully constructed one what happens
next have you have you started talking
and thinking about what's next well I
mean I think we have to understand you
can't put lipstick on a pig right so no
matter what we do we can't make this
deal look better than what it is we have
to look at the reality that this deal is
flawed so do we allow ourselves to have
blinders on to a flawed deal or do we
say what else can we do is there
something else we should be doing now to
prevent what's gonna happen ten years
from now because that's a very realistic
thing that we need to look at that's
important for our children and our
grandchildren and everything going
forward is that we can't continue to
kick this down the road we have to make
sure that we're looking out for it and I
think that if you look at North Korea
now the reasons were pushing for so many
sanctions you know do we think more
sanctions are gonna work on North Korea
not necessarily but what does it do it
cuts off the revenue that allows them to
build ballistic missiles with what we
did with Iran we cut off the revenue so
that they couldn't improve their
technology we cut off the revenue so
they couldn't do bad things willingly as
much as they wanted to so instead we
gave them this influx of money that
suddenly allowed them to do whatever
they want with twenty four days notice
if we're gonna inspect a site I mean
there's a problem there and I think we
just need to be honest with ourselves
that when the jcpoa was passed when the
resolution was passed when the corker
Cardin law was passed that doesn't
change the Iranian culture and belief of
the government they are still who they
were prior to the deal now one of the
things that you mentioned that we don't
talk about enough I think is that there
are a whole array of other Security
Council resolutions that affect Iran
that are not nuclear related not just
the missile not just the missile
technology but also the transfer of
weaponry so and you obviously mentioned
touch bola do you think that there's
support out there to start putting
pressure on the Iranians who are now in
Bahrain in Yemen in Lebanon in Syria you
know and we could go on for a while do
you think that there's a that there is a
growing consensus that we need to do
something about Iran's other activities
or is this gonna be us standing alone
again so this is the interesting thing
the Iranian you can look at any place in
the Middle East where there are problems
and the Iranian tentacles are there it's
just the reality of the situation so if
you know that if you know that there's
proof of support of terrorism if you
know there's been arms smuggling if you
know that they're in violation of
multiple things from that resolution why
isn't it anyone standing up they're not
standing up out of fear that the Iran
regime will pull out of the jcpoa
now how smart is that so we're gonna
ignore all of these things they're doing
throughout the Middle East in the name
of protecting a flawed deal that's not
smart it's not being careful it's not
being in front of the situation what we
are looking at is we are not keeping the
Iranians from doing bad things we're
empowering them and we gave them a ton
of money to do it and so we can't expect
any different behavior and they will do
exactly what they did when I went to the
IAEA to have conversations they will
threaten to pull out of the jcpoa they
are threatening the entire world because
the entire
world thinks that jcpoa is untouchable
but it's not and what they're doing is
happening with or without us and we have
to be realistic about that absolutely I
want to open things up to everybody for
questions I sure pretty much everybody's
familiar with familiar with the rules
please put your important statement in
the form of a question and raise your
hand I'll call on you and just and if
you would be nice enough to identify
yourself and wait for the mic Michael
Rubin from AEI thank you very much
governor ambassador thank you the
question I have is did the jcpoa
encourage and emboldened the reformists
in Iran are the reformists in Iran
sincere or are we caught up in a game of
good-cop bad-cop when it comes to Iran
in politics thank you so it's a great
question but I don't know that I have
the answer to it but what I do have the
answers to is the historic nature of the
Iranian regime if you look at how
they've been in the past they have
always threatened the United States they
have always done bad activity they've
always been involved in terrorism
they're not going to change their
stripes just because of a deal so what
we did is we gave them a deal what do
Iranian typically do they sidetrack the
deal they find other ways they get
creative what we know is they have hid
things in the past and they've lied
about it until they've gotten caught
this is the same scenario yes the IAEA
is doing a great job looking at declared
sites there are hundreds of undeclared
sites that have suspicious activity that
they haven't looked at so are we just
gonna go in and covet and protect this
deal and ignore the fact that reality is
they could very well be cheating like
they've done many times before and
that's why I think the United States
needs to have a conversation about are
we being smart to ourselves or are we
being played for fools there's really a
bigger question here though
it's not you know we talk a lot about
Iran we talk a lot about the bad things
that they're doing but there is actually
the nuclear non-proliferation treaty
that that stands in the balance as well
what we have North Korea we have the
Iranians we have Pakistan we have all
these other countries that now have
nuclear weapons and if the IAEA is
basically a toothless tiger then you
have to ask what purpose this is all
sawn this is all surveying I don't think
the IAEA is a toothless tiger I think
they actually do very good work they do
inspections this was a lot to give them
this was a lot you've got the fact that
there are hundreds of sites their
experts can only look at so many and
they have said of the site they've seen
those are in compliance no one's talking
about of the sites they haven't seen
that's the talking point that gets
missed it's easy to say oh but they're
in compliance well that's easy for me if
I'm asking my son did you finish your
homework and he says well I finished the
first page it's not all of the homework
and so that's a lot of what we're
talking about as we deal with this
please
I'm ambassador Lee slab it with CNN nice
to see you again I'd like to put this in
the context of North Korea right now
you're you know yesterday you said that
North Korea was begging for war today
you're talking about you know it seems
as if even though you're talking about
the president making his own decision
you just did lay out a very strong
argument for de certifying and
re-examining the deal and I'm wondering
right now as you look towards North
Korea and try to get North Korea to
abandon its nuclear ambitions whether
there's a concern that the u.s. is not
counted on to make good on the deals
that it does reach with other countries
and that North Korea will see no
incentive to make a deal with the United
States if it's going to pull out of its
deal and and just as you laid out this
case I know you said that the president
will make the decision are you
recommending that he decertified because
you certainly seem to lay out a
persuasive argument for Dee certifying
and triggering this nationwide debate
thank you so I think there's a couple of
things there I'm not making the case for
Dee certifying what I am saying is
should he decide to decertify he has
grounds to stand on that is basically
all I wanted to do was put out the facts
because I think it's very easy to just
talk about compliance in the jcpoa but
there's so much more to the story that
we need to be looking at and there's so
much more that the president has to be
looking at and so what I am doing is
just trying to lay out the options of
what's out there what we need to be
looking at and knowing that the end
result has to be the national security
of the United States it's protecting
Americans so that they aren't in danger
to threat now you talked about North
Korea and whether others would think
that we don't stay in a deal what's more
important is we let others know we will
stay in a deal as long as it protects
the security of the United State
we should at no time be beholden to any
agreement and sacrifice the security of
the United States to stay in agreement
and say that we'll do it we should
always let every country know whether
it's North Korea Iran or anyone else
that we will always look out for our
interests our security and make sure
that it's working for us not making sure
that it works for everyone else that's
very important of course the other thing
that people forget is that if the
President President Obama had submitted
this as a treaty to the Congress then we
would be much more constrained in our
ability to to walk away he chose not to
do that understanding that he probably
wouldn't get ratification but if there's
anyone to blame for the fact that now
Donald Trump can make this decision it
is in fact the previous administration
that's their call and it would be
interesting to see what the debate in
Congress would be like when they have to
look at everything when they have to
look at all aspects of corker Cardin
when they go and look at that do they
still agree with the agreement that
would be an interesting debate to see
how have you encouraged the Congress
members of Congress and Senator corkers
mr. Royce and others to hold these kind
of hearings in the run-up to to this
decision I have not had conversations
with congressional members this really
was something because we discussed it at
the United Nations quite a bit because
by instinct I tend to try and get in
front of situations before they get bad
and look at things that might happen
before they happen and because I wanted
to make sure that I provided as much
information to the President on the
issue as I could
going to the IAEA asking the right
questions saying we never asked the IAEA
to do anything they are independent I
didn't want that to half and what I did
do was ask questions how many sites how
many have you looked at are they
declared are they undeclared what about
the military sites are you checking
those all of these questions needed to
be answered and I think it all goes back
to what director general Amano said in
the very beginning this is a jigsaw
puzzle you can't look at just a few of
the pieces
and think you know the answer to the
puzzle because that's not the case for
the hello Irene Choksi what I wanted to
ask you a question that if the president
decides to decertify
the agreement and Congress has this
debate would the European allies support
where we are going if they understand
what's happening would you expect
resistance from them moving forward I
think because the European allies
understand the concerns we have with
Iran if they saw the president decertify
they would yes realize that this is
going to Congress and I think they would
watch that debate very closely no one
wants to get out of the deal out of
holding out hope that the Iranians will
do the right thing but I think we have
to be honest enough to say but what if
they're not what if they're not doing
the right thing what if we just gave
them ten years and all the money they
wanted to do whatever they want to
prepare for when that temper hits and
they start nuclear war and so I think
our European allies understand our
concerns I think that they would very
much understand the debate I think they
would have their views on whether we
should stay in or not that's gonna go on
but I think they very much would
understand our willingness or want to
have a debate on whether this is still
the right thing and shortly after the
refugee crisis of this last summer in
the previous summer they understand the
costs of allowing Iran to meddle in the
region with a free hand which is really
how absolutely Iranian seem to feel if
we're gonna have time for one more
question back there in the corner that
wait just one second please
Gardner Harris from The New York Times
miss ambassador this administration has
now thrown the dreamer and daca to
Congress it's not a debate Congress
wants it sounds like you want to throw
the Iran deal to Congress which I can
tell you right now even your allies on
the Republican side will tell you is not
a really a debate they want to have
right now on Capitol Hill
with all the things there going on this
administration has the power to decide
to stay in the dáil deal or get out of
the deal why this middle path were you
decertify and then force Congress to
make this hard decision for you instead
of making that hard decision yourself
and when I talk to the European allies
they say very clearly that they want
this deal to continue do you really
think that you will be able to persuade
them if you get out of the deal to
create an another sanctions regime when
their message during the debate was
uniformly that they would not do so
thank you for the question first of all
this is not just a middle-of-the-road
situation that's us law corker Cardin is
US law and what it says is the president
is obligated to make the decision on
whether this is still in the US national
interest what the law says is the
president has to relook at this every 90
days so that's not us trying to sidestep
that is US law and that is law that the
president has to follow and in good
conscience for all Americans we should
want the president to honestly
reevaluate every 90 days to make sure
that if things have changed we're moving
accordingly and if they haven't we're
not
I get that Congress doesn't want this
this is not an easy situation for anyone
it's not easy for the president it's not
easy for the Security Council it's not
easy for Congress but our lives are not
about being easy our lives are about
being right and we have to make sure
that every decision we make is right and
I know yes I agree with you the European
allies want us to stay in the deal
but how many attacks did I just describe
in history has the Iranian regime gone
against American our soldiers our
diplomats the Europeans can't say that
they're now having to deal with that but
again our job is not to
make sure that Europeans are happy with
us our job is to make sure we're keeping
the American public safe
that's a heavy price to pay to just try
and stay in a deal I am NOT saying this
should go to Congress I'm not saying we
should get out of the deal I'm not
saying anything in terms of what should
or shouldn't happen what I am saying is
we owe it to ourselves to look at every
aspect of this deal and understand that
this was a flawed deal and understand
that this flawed deal has negative
consequences as well
ambassador you have a tight schedule and
so I'm going to thank you
[Music]
[Applause]